how you doing I'm Matt I'm rich Matt
Iseman just worked at Richmond is the
host of American night work you know
that I'm Matt are you crazy you didn't
know hey Jim how are you how's it going
I'm a fan buddy thank you're the one
time I'm the one thank you I know I bet
when is the roast being released it
really released we're just talking about
next time I honestly to me that's a I'm
sorry to jump in right there's no going
on man the one thing I wanted to say is
like because I I love the old school
roast with like Dean and Rickles where I
felt like they were all friends right I
felt like your roast is going to be of
those ones where at the end of the day
you guys have known each other for 20
plus years and the kicks to the nuts are
all going to come with a little bit of
love and actually knowing the jokes not
just kind of someone I read something
online that you know he bought a Rolls
Royce that was used on on eBay and I'm
going to make yeah I didn't have to
research anybody write this right I'm
gonna and I said this before I've worked
on a lot of we've done tons of rows
written on rows this roast to me was
wanted everybody north everybody killed
on this roast yeah it was and it was so
much fun because it was like an
old-school roast Bobby kept standing up
and remind me of like Milton Berle when
when somebody was there so I don't
probably stand of it you know and -
honey we have fun everybody knows about
that yeah so who did the best rich know
everybody cares I never really did hear
that I already was killing from the
audience right here's the deal
everybody killed Florentine got a
standing ovation really grace yes great
he [ __ ] but I had a follow everybody
do you have an honor let me ask this I
have a nice little path there you got to
get nervous when you hear absolute
thunder and wonder if you're the one
that's going to break the streak I don't
I was going to bomb I was really that
nervous because
[ __ ] Colin and big J again luckily
Anthony try to heckle me like I was in
the club right on made me put me at ease
you know what I mean to loosen up the
fact that isn't that amazing does it
like
like Anthony that's the mindset Anthony
is yelling shitty things at you as
you're trying to perform in the audience
and that's what it takes I make you feel
comfortable like ah well that is his
home
I mean it's someone who listened I
always thought that was the best part of
the show we sitting there from the
safety of our car or whatever listening
when someone gets in the barrel and you
you could feel the tide turn you know
it's like Patrice or whoever would be
jumping in on you guys and you just hear
the desperation in your voice like a god
now all of them are focused on me III
think that's that's one of the most fun
things is just listening to someone get
[ __ ] on well that was an orange opening
line to Bonnie about how she was dressed
was so [ __ ] fun right there because
he ad-libbed his first couple of jokes
were yeah you know we're prepared and he
[ __ ] right what he said to Bonnie
about that about her you know wearing
the shirt a shirt with eight cups or
some kids or the whole [ __ ] a hole in
her shirt yeah and I said there's one
thing you should do with a cup sit show
them all right from the beginning and it
just it was it was a fun event I'm glad
that I got I only wish that Keith could
have done it yeah yeah a lot if Keith
could have done it I mean he got smashed
in the audience but I would have loved
if he was up there right you know but
the question that the man was asking
which I think because we've talked about
it now on the show
over and over again and we should you
know not to take away from it but one
would be really yeah Matt and a whole
lot of fans want to know when they can
see the sighted animals I'll tell your
truth it's it's being edited this this
is it's not an easy thing it's out of
our hands to be editing it's with the
production company although you don't
you guys will get to say well no if we
we saw an in your hand we'll get to
first cut
we'll get the first cut and we do have
creative control over okay you know
they're not telling you what comedy is
no no no but I'm we're not going to sit
on top of the first cut for two you know
what I mean why they're doing it because
you know they're gonna do close-ups
[ __ ] this whatever and then after we
look at are you cutting it is it full is
an actual length or you can have like
one words well every joke are you guys
gonna cut it down like an out it's a
good idea I don't know because how long
was it
it was like two hours I mean probably
that's when I think I would want to see
like if there were jokes that didn't do
as well I think those are the ones I
would want to see there weren't really
there were everyone's didn't do that
amazed everybody did really really
really well that's one of those ones I
think like the first Patrice benefit
where where I would have loved to have
been able to been in the room and feel
the energy and just kind of see the
people in the crowd and just hear it I
mean Louis shake helmets got a little
greedy at the end of his set but there
was also - he had a Bobby when a Norton
and Bobby killed life in the door right
from the beginning and Louis is new and
he's not you know he's a friend of mine
but he's second and third-tier he that
could be one of Louis's new credit
second or third here for the rich boss
so what is there any kind of time frame
you have any ID on whatsoever to tell
you the truth I I don't know I mean look
so let's say it doesn't get let's say
nobody buys it got if no one buys you
can you can throw them on youtube we
find a way to put it up either on a
podcast on YouTube and then charge
people two dollars for it I would pay
for the director's cut of rich like
explaining why that's so funny on it
like some specific if there were jokes
where it's like not totally clear of the
battery you you you telling the
backstory of where like where Robert
Kelley like okay this girl came up from
what if you know you go back and explain
before yesterday's [ __ ] like just do
I know
give me the Paula I've been listening to
you for like 20 years of these guys so
we get familiar that's the problem is we
think we were in but where where you
based out of I'm based out of LA I live
in LA
alright so that's where when people
listen so long and they know your
[ __ ] life you know you and let me
tell you here's a conversation yeah I
don't know what exhibited weird way does
that and he's like trying to I think
that it's like this artful thing awesome
every time
yes sir evacuate yeah we were talking
exactly profiling like mid-conversation
as soon as he was like two where you
based out of I was like he's just trying
to he's just trying to shift the comfort
waist I'll work with me right now he's
trying to believe the conversation over
a different direction he doesn't know
where to find him I didn't know where
and I'll tell you why I was doing that
because if he lived like say he was
based out of Connecticut or maybe out of
Philly I could have said hey I'm working
in these places but how about that great
honey but he goes in LA and rich goes I
have no work in Los Angeles I'm not
going to do an hour in Los Angeles where
you gonna do an improv huh he booked The
Improv do an hour even when I hate
you're out there I could be a miner one
of those I get to Melrose I'm probably
hour when I headlined it oh you did yeah
I did I do like lot of Hamelin
entertainment find work in Holland as in
kind listen you're gonna go I did
actually I did a an hour at the ice
house you're we're okay live in LA right
now so I become confirms you know just a
long time in LA at times yeah you can
get you can do long long sets in LA if
you can use 15-minute sets sure Wow okay
yeah you do them too cool I like it 15
minutes
no I don't either no you get himself out
yeah I don't like them you know all
jokes aside I don't like the 15 minutes
to Beshear's write it down
oh my go on record I'm not a big fan
show you promoting this noose year this
new season
ah wait so we're we're in the middle of
the season of American Ninja Warrior we
just last night started the city finals
so that we just did the six city
qualifiers and then the six city finals
but I have I have an apology gift for
you okay because I last time I was in
here behind I know him on the celebrity
ninja warrior and I did I made inquiries
I don't obviously Dianna say I'm not a
celebrity that they're always going to
reject me those places yeah and you know
they did have a couple comedians on
there's honor Jeff died who's on an NBC
show
he's on better late than never okay I
don't can yeah I know his name okay but
that's that I judge a guy and
Glaser counter to but yet has anything I
you when I rich I didn't know this would
probably fit roads thank you
but Jeff's got an NBC show so there's
like a function yeah and you know you
know how uh nikki is is a younger girl
and she looks like Jessie Graff
so from put in my book Jimmy I know
these were the muscle shirts for my arms
are great I know I might like I was
looking for something sleeveless for the
spot in my book Jimmy I would love to be
on your honor
thank you very much it's okay cuz you're
a star to me thank you very much Steve
ridgway's our exec who worked with us
tonight show I think okay let's judge if
you remember him but you know he
probably didn't know he he said Jim was
one of the funniest guys we'd ever had
who every he said every second you did
you'd have at least one or two minds
that would kill the room mat division
showbiz is nobody will tell you they
don't like you in show business they
don't ever time they don't there's no
way that I could you don't show business
thank you for the gift yes
yeah there's no advantage for them to
tell you we don't like rice you know
they just don't but I said when did this
house Vicki when it's on Monday oh I
think so we shot the dead aired in May
that was part of Red Nose Day Chris
Hardwick was hosting that and we did
like the celebrity version Nikki did
okay she got through an obstacle in
there but it was the celebrity version
was a little a little less stringent on
the rules usually the show is you know
you touch the water you fall it's over
and I'm the celebrity version there were
a little more generous okay on Nikki do
well Jeff die did very well he got up
the Warped wall on his first try I mean
you should see this show the obstacles
are so hard they're so hard how but
unbelievable these obstacles are so hard
to get up it you wouldn't believe it
are you making fun of my other boss yeah
I uh right he was your own apprentice
Technic oh yeah I saw the one-legged guy
on your show Zach Allen yeah he's
amazing I mean it's it's been incredible
we've had a few people with the
amputations and they make the
distinction of below the knee or above
the knee
below the knee you retain the knee
joints so physiologically you're able to
do a lot more movement this guy had lost
it above the knee and you know I'm
WWE you get the [ __ ] kicked out of him
by Brock Lesnar right yeah I mean like
the guy's 180 pounds Bridey losing my
leg yes sir yeah childhood it was born
had to had to lose the leg and so he
came on the show and this is this will
go over really well in this room I know
it's like a show though where it's it's
relentlessly positive where you have
these things
it's that was so perfectly what you said
this is so awesome Jimmy sitting among
Jimmy buttons we collagen yeah you've
got every button it's fine but yeah it's
a go it's it's positive and how would
you have young a young daughter right I
have to I have a 27 year old 26 year old
$25 gonna be a 10 year old sorry you
know it's a show like okay all kids are
like a cancer that is three I know it's
been fun it's been fun being a part of a
show that it started on cable and was
nothing on g4 look at the guns why you
think I just want to his back Yeah right
I have wrong got it except no he doesn't
and rolling why you thinking you had all
- Jesus if it's positive president yeah
right you're going to take his shirt and
he almost took I had water all against
English - what a [ __ ] cool we doing
boys and his shirt off and he's flexing
his muscle so he can see impacts that's
not even a good six-pack yeah no it's
pretty good dude it's pretty good he's
looking like Danny Trejo now he is that
is a death of Danny Trejo ladies like it
ends in another month prison action hero
you have no underwear on yeah I do I
don't see I don't see no there it is so
what are you doing you've been working
out how you can walk down a lot rich
alright I always worked out he always
works out I cut out I'm trying to cut
out there's much gluten as I can i
boring how many I set up today to do I
do them every other day how many 1000
crunches and I do plan development stick
out a little bit yeah a little bit a
little perseverance yes pretty sure I'm
back with you I was right you're only 60
why would you know that by now we put a
shirt on wrong if that long before the
rest of us workout series out
yeah yeah you're right true well you
know it so here's when you're under rope
so much is so hard
to eat well right by the way this is it
how good shape he's in he's got a
six-pack but he's out of breath from
taking uh not making attention to the
cardio some I don't care about the
inside right they see outside that's
true you know it's all it's you know
everybody thinks it's about you know
treadmill and yeah but it's diet it's
all yeah it's a [ __ ] diet
oh my god so I hit the but dude I hit
the [ __ ] by didn't mean to pick up on
this call Jerry buttons I asked you to
mediate on now with the hello who's this
rich yeah I actually I a buddy I
actually hit the number by actually hit
this button my mistake that's Jimmy
button sometimes I guess that's
unpredictable that's the way God wanted
it so we'll talk to you what's up minute
I just want to say hey rich I'm a fan
rich boss but uh I got some comments
about okie run uh all right well if you
can't you keep it free just because
we're in the middle of it saying I
didn't mean to pick you up yeah
somewhere pot and we love that Wigga
rich though so this is a nice look
erection oh I thought you meant this one
yeah new nickname foreigner that yes
rich oh oh yeah I'm back um yeah like
I'm pretty disturbed that he likes
filming a weak man take [ __ ] well um and
yet very large breasts as well you don't
need to worry about it anymore all right
Richie appreciate I you can call anytime
I've learned the mill the same with Matt
but I guess healing begun yeah obviously
right yeah we're all doing good anyways
good now no notice like I said all right
Thank You Alicia everybody's cool um oh
my god there's a Photoshop wait what's
the Twitter name of the guy who did it
at like Jefferson Hef Jefferson I took
rich with no shirt on and added a lot of
weight to the torso titties and
appointed read more quickly they did it
to looking at me see your nipples he
looks like a dwarf the port routing
forehead is really bad
haha Oh today I forgave out my password
within a minute I was on every gay site
is my daughter forever yeah but what did
they do to you different exactly am i
doing am i doing this is there anything
you want to tell me did she listen to
your stuff now
yeah but end urology's she comes on our
podcast she kills kills do you so funny
do you have any insight about that day
because that day that you gave out your
password is I mean it's probably it's my
favorite day have been alive so far and
I mean I've been married I have a child
like that still enjoy that when he did
it it's my favorite thing that's ever
happened and I mean I've a lots happened
to me even professionally and still
that's my favorite day on the planet
why would you think that your Twitter
username with comics 6:3 wonder your
password for your Twitter Facebook email
like that was your past people pick up
on it immediately they said they said
what's your Twitter address and was just
announced his password for all of his
except on the air and negotiate to get
your account back yeah I called my web
guy he just [ __ ] no no no I took your
email Travis took your facebook one of
the fans took your Twitter account and
you had to negotiate with everybody the
web guy got your email back but you had
to negotiate with Travis T at your
Facebook you had to negotiate with a
caller to get your Twitter back I have a
particular set of skills we have we have
the clip you do yeah we have the clip
yeah we do yeah bad Oh God what is your
Twitter name much loss what was the
thing you said earlier
what would the comic thing I don't know
don't say it cuz it might be so what is
your Twitter name like if someone wants
to see your Twitter what would they have
to type in to see your Twitter wait till
you hear this one Jimmy what is your
Twitter name root loss so then why go to
wwe.com slash
Rick Vaughn and you gotta Mallory I
gotta okay so what we know what was the
thing you said earlier and what was the
thing earlier oh we don't have the
original thing Travis Nigeria raise your
hands giving it away yeah I want it I
just asked yeah I don't want to hear the
aftermath I wanna hear you give me a
second okay although that sound that
realization of all Oh picture all clean
okay no why would I try to why look we
did we do we just leave it the picture
just leave it Lindsey yeah you look at
you only a [ __ ] in shaped or dude I'd
be psyched to have that body rich that
is that's impressive but no why did you
think that your password was your
username we don't to it but it's called
a sighs I've never heard of anybody
getting those two things confused well
now you have no I guess I didn't say
that you know was just stunning that he
did that all right I've never stunningly
stupid because they're so different
right like your username is something
you want everybody to know and your
password is something you wouldn't even
want anybody to guess I I would go
Calgary without good to V this
interchangeable well you know it's just
things are moving so quick in here and
there's I though there's so much the
talent is is crazy so you're just boom
boom boom and all of a sudden you make a
mistake and that mistake cost you
everything
volunteer we have we have it Rizvan here
you go for rich vos rich vos comm rich
vos on MySpace yeah what's your wish for
today
I don't [ __ ] Twitter which boss
Twitter I don't have you have twitter I
Twitter all the time I got hugging I
love it I don't quit I'm asking away you
just say you don't know how to do I
don't know what you can give a Twitter
address holy [ __ ]
I don't know promotion for your Twitter
today Toyota Ridge loss I guess no it's
not that
what is it it's certainly not that did
you pick a name when you signed up for
Twitter yeah I think so oh my god don't
you know what you don't get into
promotion for your twitter comic strick
30 I think so
Thomas 6:35 nothing wrong with you in
the euro oh my god don't send him rich
box
all right response that was great that
was great I think the best thing to
would be that he's not on his phone he's
not on the screen everyone else in here
is so the jokes going on yeah as people
are hacking his accounts and he'd be the
only one who wouldn't be aware of it at
that point the common 360 was his
password
yeah they figured out right away and
then once they figured out it was
Twitter then they started we thank God
for the seven second delay because as
soon as somebody figured out it was
Twitter all of us like minions around
here started walking into all of his
other account well I'm grabbing him
that's that we got them all it was the
same password for everything I'll bet
there's still accounts out there that he
owned that he didn't change the panel I
did I don't have that anywhere what's
your new password I don't tell you now
oh yeah